Now that you understand how to
interpret the results of the geocoding
web service, let's switch back
to the JavaScript API and
incorporate it into our app.
We'll use the geocoding service client
side, since we'll need user input.
The user searching for
a new home may want to indicate
a location to base their search around.
One way to do that would be to have
them enter a point of interest,
a neighborhood or an address.
After they do that we
can center our map and
zoom it around that location
instead of showing the entire city.
So, we'll define another
user input here in our HTML.
I'm calling this zoom-to-area-text
because I'll prompt the user to focus on
an area of the city.
This would be useful if
we had a ton of listings.
We'll also add a zoom button and
a horizontal rule to keep
our page a little neater.
I'm also adding some more CSS.
Next, we'll create an event listener
in our initialized function, so that
when the zoom to area button is clicked
we call our zoom to area function.
Which we'll create below.
The goal of this zoom to area function
is to take the user entered address,
geocode it to get the lat-long, and
then center the map on that lat-long and
zoom in.
The first thing we'll do is
create a new geocoder instance.
We'll then capture the user entered
address and make sure it isn't blank.
Finally we'll geocode that address.
We're also adding in a component
restriction here to keep it within
the city so that they don't enter
an address outside of New York City.
After we get the results,
we'll check our geocoder status to
make sure it's okay, and then we'll
use the resulting lat long we got
back to recenter the map and zoom in.
If the results were not okay,
we'll give the user a message that we
can't find the location they entered.
We could also show some
more information here.
Such as the actual status code received.
So, if Ajay looks for Ajay land, we
could let him know we didn't find it as
opposed to letting him know that we
got a server error or something.
All right let's give this a go.
I'm going to zoom in
on the East Village.
Boom, now the user can zoom in
on the Upper East Side, SoHo,
the East Village, any area that they're
interested in looking at houses within.
So it's getting easier and easier for
the user to see exactly what
listing they're interested in.
Let's practice what we've
learned about geocoding.